hi everyone welcome to the simply line
youtube channel this session will be
about creating a telecom board using
python but before we begin if you love
watching tech videos subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
in this session we will create a simply
learn board that will help that soothers
to choose from various courses offered
by simpler
now let's understand the uses of boards
the first use of bot is
to get customized notifications and news
a board can act as a
smart newspaper sending relevant content
to its subscribers as soon as it's
published
the next use
is accept payments a board can offer
paid services or work as a virtual
storefront
and other users create custom tools
a board may provide with alerts whether
forecasts translations formatting or
other services
and
another uses build social services
a board could connect people looking for
conversation partners based on common
interest or proximity
with the understanding of uses of bots
now let's create our own word
you will have to follow the steps to
create a telegram board
and the first requirement to create a
port is you should have a telegram
account
now let's move to telegram
and using the telegram we will interact
with the telegram portfolio which is
going to provide us with the port and
the token which will act as a password
for that port
and then we will create a python program
to do all these interactions
so you need to get the telegram app
whether on the desktop or in your mobile
phone i am going to use desktop versions
you can download the desktop app from
desktop.telegram.org
i will show you how to download it
desktop.telegram
dot org
here you can see that windows bit 64
version is available
and you can see all the platforms
and you can choose according to your
needs
i have installed the windows 64-bit
version
and
the telegram app
i will search for the board further
and be careful and click on the verified
one with the blue deck this is the one
just click on it
and you can click on the start to start
the conversation with the board further
you can see the various commands
here
and board further is again a bot which
telegram has created in order to do
automation of all the board creations
and now to create a new board we'll
start with the command slash new board
here you can see this is the command you
can click on that or just right here
slash
new bot
now the father board has replied all
right a new bot
how are we going to call it please
choose a name for a bot so here you have
to choose a name for your board
i will go with the name of skill by
simply learn for my board
now the fatherboard has replied good now
let's choose a username for your word it
must end in both like this for example
tetrisport or tetris underscoreboard
you need to make sure that the username
is unique and it ends with underscore
port
or it should have bought at the end of
the username
but further will inform you if your
username is already taken so i would be
going with the username
upscale underscore one one two two
just simply learn
underscore
both
and the board for the replied done
congratulations on your new board you
will find it at
this is the link hey if you click it you
will just
get to your board
and we have received the token for our
board
here you can see use this token to
access the http api this is your token
and the board further said keep your
token secure and store it safely it can
be used by anyone to control your board
as soon as you receive that open you
have to write another command that is
slash
set privacy
and press enter
it will change the privacy settings for
a board so no one can misuse your port
token
and now you have to choose the port you
want to change the privacy settings
so we are currently working on the
upscale underscore 112 underscore simply
learn
we'll choose this
and here you can see that the security
is enabled you have to write disable or
choose disable from here
now success the new status is disabled
so your bot is now secure and your token
can't misused by anyone else
this is how we created a port and now
we'll use this in python program
first we will see the external packages
we need to install for this project
for that
we will move to command prompt
and install the packages
the first package is prep
install
python
hyphen telegram python board
as you can see the package is already
installed on my system so you have to
install the package
and then open your idle
for that i will create a folder
and i will name it as telegram board
and inside i will open my id id for that
i'll write the command cmd
and
open my visual studio board
now i will create a new file and name it
as
telegram
dot py
and now
first thing i will do is import
telegram.ext
now we are going to load the token
provided by the board further so we will
move to
telegram
and copy the token provided by the board
further
so this is our token
we'll copy it and move back to our
ideally
and create a new variable
that would be token
a token
in it
now we will create the updater object
this object will be used to perform
actions with our board
so we are going to write the command
updater
equal to telegram
dot ext
dot
updater
and
will pass the token and use context
equal to true in it
first we will copy our
token and
pass another variable
that is use underscore context
and that would be equal to true
and now we're going to get the
dispatcher we will create a variable
with the name
dispatcher
and that would hold
updater
load dispatcher
now we'll add the functions to give our
board some functionalities
we will start with the start command if
the first command usually given to the
board
for that we will write
define that would be defining the
function
with the name start
and inside we will pass update
and context
as we have used the use underscore
context as true we will use the context
for some information
and when someone starts the conversation
with a board what should be a first
message
we'll set the first message as welcome
to simply learn for that you will write
update dot
message
dot
reply
underscore text
and inside will store a message
that would be hello
welcome to simply learn
next we will define another function
that is help
and for that we will write the command
india
help
and will pass the same update and
context
and inside this function
we will send the message with the
commands
that would be start help content and the
python playlist or sql playlist
java pages that the user wants to
persuade or which course he want to
persuade
so we will start with
date
dot
message dot reply
underscore text
and inside
we will define all the commands
we'll go with the triple columns
so our first one would be start
and it would symbolize
welcome to the channel
and our next one would be help only
and it would indicate
this particular message
the next command will define as content
and this would be about various
playlists of simpler
the next will start with the python
playlist
and
if the user
write this command to a board he will
just direct it to the first video from
the python playlist
and next command we will write about sql
and it would also direct it
to the first video
from sequel playlist
and the next up command would be about
java
and it would also direct to the first
video from the java playlist
and we would also set another command
that would be contact
and that would hold the contact
information if someone wants to contact
to simply learn from further information
and now
we will define all these commands
for that
we'll
write the function
and content and will pass
update
and
context
and
inside
will just uh output
to the users
with the command update dot message
dot reply underscore text
and the output that what users will see
is we have various playlists and
articles available
and now similarly we will
update the next function
we will copy this
token would paste it
here we will
copy the function
and
next function would be python
so
if the user type python in the chat bot
so he will just direct it to the first
video from python playlist
for that
copy the link of the
first video from the playlist
python
and paste in the message dot reply
underscore text
and for that we'll write
tutorial link
and paste the link of the video
and now we'll do the same
for sql and java
we will copy the function
and change the name to the sql
and copy the link
of the first video sequel from the
playlist
and now we will do the same for the java
for that we will copy the function
and paste here and name it as java
now we will move to the java playlist
and copy the link of the first video
from playlist
and paste it here
now we are done with the functions
python sql java and we are left with
contact so we will declare another
function
for that also we will
copy the same function
and name it as contact
and inside
you can contact
the registered mail id
provide it on the website
so these are some functions which we can
add to the dispatcher we will create a
command handler to handle the certain
command and map the function to it and
then add the command handler to the
dispatcher
so first we will write the command
that is
dispatcher
dot add underscore handler
and inside
we will write telegram
dot ext dot command handler
and inside we will pass
the name of the command that will be
inputted by the user and the function
name
for that
all right
first we'll write the command
that is
start and the function defined
by us for the command start
is also with the name start
now we'll copy this command
and
do the needful for all the functions
so here we will
change the command
that would be python
and the function name
and the same for sql
and simple java
and we're left with the last
command that is contact
and in the end
we'll write
command updated dot start
underscore polling
so it will check
if our code is working or not
and updater
dot idle
it is used when the user just enters the
first command
so it will not exit the program it will
wait for user to enter other commands
always forgot to write a command for
help
for that we'll copy the command
right help will save the program
and
click on the run button
here we can see that the program is
running fine
now we'll move to the telegram
and
click on our port username you can also
search the for our board username here
it's globally searchable
now we'll click on the start
so
the start command
we have got the output hello welcome to
simply learn
now we will
put slash help
and here we have got all the commands
that is lets start
slash help and this particular message
will appear when we click on the slash
help or just write it here
when you click on slash python you will
get the first video from the python
playlist and when we click on the slash
sql
will get the first
video from the sql playlist
and similar with the java
we'll get the first video from the job
playlist
and when we
click on the command slash contact we
get the output you can contact on the
registered main id provided on the
website
so we have done with our telegram board
we have created this telecom board
successfully that we have come to the
end of this session
i hope it was interesting and
informative if you liked it please let
us know in the comment section below
also do subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here